let's get the views now of the former
brexit secretary add Dominic RAF who
joins us know at mr. up thanks for
joining us keeping drive very very wise
and just to start I mean I do wonder man
mister uh are you missing the job a
brexit secretary right now I mean
there's certainly plenty going on yes I
certainly miss the challenge of it and
it was in sorry not in anger that I
stepped down but I just in good
conscience didn't feel I could rep
recommend the deal that was presented in
the final terms agreed at the end to the
country I suspect then that your view
and that has has not changed nothing
that you heard yesterday either from
your colleagues and the back benches or
indeed from the prime minister itself
you are still firmly of the opinion that
this is a bad deal at one to be avoided
so what else is there that we can do yes
in fact I'm strengthened in that view
not least since the publication the
legal advice which makes very clear that
under this deal under the backstop as
it's called would be signing up to a
whole suite of laws and regulations
under which we'd have no say and no
ability to exit and that would be
actually a starting point not the end
point for the future relationship no
democratic country and history is signed
up to that in answer to your second
question if Parliament votes this down
what should we do in my view the Prime
Minister's at her best when she stands
tall and stands strong and we should go
back to the EU stop being blackmailed
and bullied make our best final offer
the terms that would be palatable to
this country that would give affect the
referendum and it could be very clear if
are reasonable and common-sense
approaches not accepted we would in the
last analysis be willing to walk away in
terms of heading back to Brussels I mean
what an F do you think that can be
possibly achieved there particularly
given the major sticking point appears
to be the backstop and as things stand
as yet we still have no practical
solution to the problem of the border on
the island of Ireland well I don't agree
with that I think there are a range of
technological solutions which coupled
with goodwill on both sides could
resolve this and that's also by the way
the view if you listen to John Thompson
head of HMRC I've been down to the the
border area at South Armagh from Nuri
right the way across to cross mcglennan
I've looked very carefully at the
situation I've taken it very seriously
I think actually what the EU is trying
to do is not resolve the substantive
issue around the border between the
Republic and Northern Ireland which is
an issue we need to address what they
tried to do is massively politicize it
it's been politicized in Dublin and it's
been used by Brussels as a way of
controlling the UK and trying to stop us
take the advantages grasp the advantages
of brexit and that's just blackmail and
we shouldn't succumb to that but in
terms of that amendment that Dominic
Greve managed to get through with the
assistance of among others Michael
Fallon Oliver let one of all people I
mean what is your review of that does
that give the House of Commons
essentially a sign off on whatever plan
becomes and do you accept the fact that
it will be those who are at brexit
supporters amongst your colleagues who
see that option who might know votes for
this deal where previously they might
not well I can't speak for MPs will be
deciding in the balance but what is
clear is that the vote yesterday will
not affect the the ultimate outcome
because votes in Parliament on notions
are not legally binding so if no no
absolutely absolutely okay yep but
politically I understand the legal up
their legal argument but politically are
you saying that that could be ignored by
the government look to reverse the
course of breaks it will require
legislation or lack of will in number 10
Downing Street and I believe this Prime
Minister Keith is true to her word that
she's going to deliver brexit she always
said No Deal was better than a bad deal
nothing if Parliament turns is still
down we shouldn't flounce off we should
go back and make a reasonable best final
offer to Brussels but ultimately we do
need to be willing to walk away that's
the only way in any negotiation you get
sensible you're arguing you're arguing
that you're ignoring the will of the
House of Commons that didn't work out
very well for you yesterday did it what
well I'm just no what I'm doing is
setting the clear constitutional
position which is motions of Parliament
are politically
have weight for sure but they don't
legally bind the government and what
matters right now both domestically but
also in Brussels is political resolve
and will so let's just be clear Dominic
Greene's amendment doesn't matter
it didn't matter I said I didn't have
legally binding force and therefore it
cannot alone stop Breck
to reverse the outcome and the outcome
is that unless something changes matters
we will leave EU at the end of March
with a deal or without a deal I would
like us to get a deal but we're going to
have to be much tougher with Brussels
much firmer and more resolute if we're
going to get them to take us more
seriously okay simple question if if as
we all assume Tuesday goes badly for the
prime minister and she does indeed take
your advice head to Brussels to try and
at flush out something are some more
compromises would you be happy with
article 50 being paused at that point
together the time no I don't think the
issue is why not because it's not time
we need it's its decisions and I think
all that we'd end up doing is kicking
the can down the road and I don't think
that's necessary I think we need to make
the decisions now but in terms of
getting what you want a deal which
allows us to strike our own FTAs but at
the same time allows us our sovereignty
and our integrity I mean wouldn't you be
prepared to give the Prime Minister the
time to secure that if securing it were
possible so but and by the way what
you're talking about is what the vast
majority of countries around the world
enjoy so we're not asking for something
particularly outrageous or special and I
think we've had to use these
negotiations and I don't think we would
be more likely to get compromise from
the EU if they thought they could string
us out just for a little bit longer then
we're more likely to get compromised
pragmatism a bit more goodwill from the
EU if they know is serious about walking
away from a lousy deal which is what
this is just reminders mr. rubb have you
submitted a letter to the chairman of
the 1922 no and I support this prime
minister and I want to see him make a
successor brexit